[Music]  what's your name you know what what's  your next stop kind of just let the road  tell me where to go  Society will be munched butter off to  build an army of self-sufficient  agitators not everyone wants to live  like us of course they do  [Music]  nolé and i are just going back to orbits  where are you driving to in the middle  of the night  [Music]  what's up little lady it's some antique  you got here what the hell are you doing  working for you you need the help and I  need the repairs everyone has a bomb  what happened to yours  [Music]  phears the only thing holding these  people back they've got their driveways  they've got their backyards and got  their pools we have our freedom  [Music]  [Music]  you